in this video we will try to plot
rational numbers whose numerators are
greater than their denominators let us
plot 7 by 4 and minus 7 by 4 we try to
plot 7 by 4 first the first step in such
kind of problems where the numerator is
greater than the denominator is to
convert it into a mixed fraction form
you would have learned this in your
earlier classes but let me quickly show
you how we only have to divide 7 by 4 we
get the quotient as 1 and the remainder
as 3 so we write the mixed fraction as
quotient remainder by divisor this is
the whole part and this is the
fractional part so we can write 7 by 4
as 1 3 by 4 1 is called the whole number
part and 3 by 4 is called the proper
fraction part each of the 3 numbers 1 3
& 4 tell us something about where 7 by 4
is plotted on the number line the whole
number part tells us the position of 7
by 4 so 1 tells us that the rational
number 7 by 4 is between itself and the
next whole number the next whole number
is 2 so we know that 7 by 4 is between 1
& 2 so we draw the number line
accordingly with just 0 1 & 2 marked the
denominator of the proper fraction part
tells us the number of equal parts this
segment is divided into since it is 4 we
divide this segment into 4 parts this
segment between 1 & 2 is divided into
four equal parts the numerator of the
proper fraction tells us the number of
parts from the first whole number so it
is 3 parts away from 1 so we mark 7 by 4
here
what about minus 7 by 4 we can write
minus 7 by 4 as minus 1 3 by 4 now the
number minus 1 tells us that minus 7 by
4 is between itself and the next number
make note of the fact that the next
number will be on the left hand side
since minus 7 by 4 is a negative
rational number so the next number is
minus 2 now we can say that minus 7 by 4
is between minus 1 and minus 2 the
denominator tells us the number of equal
paths this length is divided in two so
we divide it into four equal parts by
marking three lines the number three
tells us the number of paths from the
number minus one so leaving three paths
from minus one we mark minus 7 by 4 here
with that we are done with the topic of
plotting positive and negative rational
numbers please practice this concept
thoroughly and make note of the summary
which appears at the end of this video